[Musique]
j'accueille jamiroquai
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
soir
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir jay kay le leader du groupe
jamiroquai 20 millions d'albums vendus
et quand on écoute on comprend pourquoi
didier
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
[Musique]
s
[Applaudissements]
à
entre nous
[Musique]
ah bon
là
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ouais
regardons
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
jamais ô toi
voilà après presque quatre ans d'absence
jamiroquai sort un nouvel album le 20
juin
il s'appelle dynamite est le premier
single c
[Musique]
là
m
[Musique]
oh
jamiroquai
[Applaudissements]
je vis
le temps elle
qu'ils s'appellent dynamo points alors
je vais pas réussi à joindre en landau
mais je suis sûr qu'ils exigent le clip
so please jamiroquai et je pourrai
regarder votre caméra c'est le cas leur
lumière rouge et vous dites magnéto
serge magnéto serge manière sèche bravo
[Applaudissements]
jamiroquai au mieux nos jean michel
jarre yann jean michel jarre évidemment
je le collège oui oui je suis un grand
fan de jean michel jarre est ce que
jean-michel pour venir pour serrer la
main de jamiroquai
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors jean michel jamiroquai vient de
dire qu'il était un grand fan de un
grand fan de vous est ce que vous êtes
un grand fan de lui voulait absolument
basse et c'est vraiment quelqu'un qui
est qui a un style totalement
particulier qui use je pense qu'on se
retrouve c'est qu'il a une manière de
traiter le son qui est totalement unique
dans dans un 2e catégorie de musique
totalement différente mais mais c'est
avant tout du son du maroc c'est pour ça
que depuis le départ moi c'est quelqu'un
qui m'a branché mini diatement
indépendamment de son son talent de
performeurs et de haut niveau du son
c'est vraiment quelqu'un qui
immédiatement ses s'est décalé par
rapport à tout un genre de musique qui
existaient et qui en a fait une pâte qui
viennent il ya une patte unique très
particulier il te connais d'accord mais
d'oyono jean pierre raffarin de notre
énergie là merci jean michel merci
d'être venu saluer johnny
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'allusion du sol
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
[Musique]
alors j'allais en quoi il saura une
grande tournée européenne cet été il
sera le 21 juillet à golfe juan et le 22
juillet à nîmes voilà donc si vous
voulez mais allez le voir voilà alors
jamiroquai quand on s'interroge sur
cette grâce ce que vous avez dans la
dans la composition musicale et dans
l'interprétation vocale
en fait on trouve la réponse dans votre
biographie votre mère car hennequet
s'élancer à 14 ans dans une carrière de
chanteuse de jazz
à 17 ans elle était sur la même scène
que les beatles que ronnie scott ou
dizzy gillespie
est-ce que c'est finalement sac c'est
cette jeunesse baigné dans la musique
qui vous a donné cette grâce oui
absolument
effectivement ma mère une influence très
importante sur moi depuis que j'étais
tout gamin
moi j'étais dans le coup lice j'étais
souvent avec les musiciens là et elle a
peint s'occuper des musiciens et les
enfants le musicien ou mais en fait bien
sûr ça quand elle était sûre celle là
elle avait pu le temps occupé de moi
évidemment il y avait des bombes des
crampes des grands et nord qui jouait ya
de bonnes passes 3 ans c'était vraiment
tous le sont tous à la musique que j'ai
entendu qui va percer mon enfance et
donc c'était vraiment l'influencent
numéro un pour moi s'il très bonne école
pour vous effectivement et à l'âge de 4
ans pendant un show de votre mère vous
entrez sur scène en criant maman maman
maintenant vous en souvenez de sa belle
parce que très bien avoir traversé les
danseuses et bon c'est pour ça que
j'aime autant l'échiné chaussures à
l'heure actuelle parce que j'étais
toujours encadré de flics étaient
grandes
grandes jambes des gens de chaussures
qui avaient des branches mais c'était
son sac j'ai un peu fétiche question de
chaussures notamment alors à la même
époque
votre premier grand témoin musical c'est
shaft parise accueil ça a été vraiment
pour vous une révélation
james avait tellement sur moi c'est
incroyable
ou est ce que c'est un faux nom mais
c'est vrai c'est super dur et oui vous
avez raison
effectivement mon père avait une table
et puis elle un petit tracteur un rouge
et moi je pédalais là autour de ça on a
une tronche allait vraiment la première
chose je voudrais bien voir aussi que
faisait partie ma mère faisait partie de
baby doll 164 à jouer dans un club avant
qu'il soit vraiment très connu donc
effectivement c'est quelque chose qui
s'inscrit dans la durée toutes cette
histoire avec la musique
maintenant il faut que vous me demandiez
ce que vous me disiez ce que j'ai prévu
donc voilà comment s'explique le goût
musical de jamiroquai et son instabilité
aussi et puis alors on découvre quand on
étudie un petit peu votre biographie
pourquoi vous aimez tellement les
voitures c'est parce que votre mère
n'avait pas de véritable pied-à-terre et
vous avez passé une bonne partie de
votre enfance à l'arrière des voitures
ce qui explique votre passion pour les
bolides sans doute vous demandiez à
votre mère d'accélérer quand vous étiez
sur la route avec elle hier voilà à
leicester effectivement c'est vrai que
j'adore toujours les sièges arrière des
blessures d'ailleurs mais vous voyez en
fait effectivement c'est vrai que j'ai
grandi sur les autoroutes
c'est là que c'est là que me vient cet
amour qu'on les bouscule
parce que quand vous devez déplacer aux
quatre coins du pays à longueur de temps
et bien tout ce qu'il vous reste à faire
si regardez les bagnoles et donc ils
violent les 70 c'était très différent
tous plus intéressantes qu'elles ne le
sont à l'heure actuelle elle avait une
triumph bottemer il avait une triumph
très stressante
alors voilà c'est pas facile quand on
est enfant de bouger de faire des études
jamiroquai jay kay a eu une enfance un
peu compliqué il en pense pas facile à
l'époque votre mère travaille beaucoup
parfois vous rentrez chez vous il ya
personne qu'on vous rentrez et vous
n'êtes pas assez grand pour mettre la
clé dans la serrure et vous êtes obligés
d'aller voir les voisins en pleurant
pour qui vous ouvre la porte de chez
vous ce n'était pas drôle tous les jours
j'ai pu être en internat
dès l'âge de 4 ans j'étais jeune gamin
de l'école j'ai été dans cet internat
différents tout simplement parce que ma
mère devait travailler et donc les gens
ont frappé dès le premier jour tout
simplement parce que j'avais parlé à nos
camarades pendant le repas du soir en
fait j'avais pas nous aviez droit de
parler
certaines personnes mais bon papa lui en
l'occurrence et donc c'était très
strictes et donc ils m'ont ils m'ont
battu et je pense que ça m'a donné
l'indépendance dont je jouais à l'heure
actuelle
et il faut bien voir ainsi que ça a
développé en moi cette indépendance vous
savez qu'il faut grandir rapidement
qu'il faut faire ses preuves
voilà alors en parlant d'indépendance à
l'âge de 16 ans vous discutez avec votre
mère vous devenez tagueurs vous allez
vivre dans un squat ou fait des petits
boulots et vous avez même vendu du shit
c'est vrai vous avez vendu du haschich
jay kay a conduit du chiffre mais vous
je pourrais d'ailleurs bien fut même
toujours non ce serait sympa il ya des
fois où il ya des moments où c'est
mouillé faire de la musique et bien à ce
moment là vous allez faire tous les
efforts il faut pour y arriver est
effectivement là je me suis rendu compte
qu'il fallait que je fasse un certain
nombre d'efforts avec le fasse un
certain nombre de choses que je récupère
l'argent nécessaire pour compte pour
m'acheter de matériel dont j'avais
besoin pour me lancer
et puis ensuite j'ai pu sortir de tout
ça et oui moi je savais ce que je
voulais faire c'était j'avais quelque
chose de faisait le fixe est là dessus
sur la musique c'était ce que je voulais
c'était vraiment fait du hasch libanais
de stupide que ça en fait plein de
petits boulots pour essayer d'accumuler
de l'argent vous n'êtes pas très heureux
à cette époque là et un jour vous vous
dites si tu veux faire de la musique
fait de la musique ne fait plus que de
la musique
même si tu dois mourir de faim à ce
moment là vous retournez chez votre mère
vous vous enfermez pendant six semaines
dans la salle de bains transformé en
studio et là vous créez en très peu de
temps en fait le concept jamiroquai et
le logo le logo avec les buffalos
manière que vous inventez ça très
rapidement finalement j'ai voulu sortir
de tous les problèmes
je traverse est donc rentrée chez moi
j'étais dans ma chambre je me suis assis
là et je me suis dit bon alors qu'est ce
que je vais faire maintenant il faut que
je fasse quelque chose que je présente
quelque chose à l'entreprise j'ai dit ce
que l'on produit fini est donc ce que je
ne trouvais pas de nom pour le groupe
donc la première chose que j'ai faite
c'est que j'ai essayé de résister signer
ce type là bon et signer parce que je me
suis dit que c'est qu'un symbole que les
gens les reconnaît facilement et je me
suis dit pas si le voit régulièrement
ils vont le reconnaître même s'il ya pas
de nom et c'est le cas voilà alors le
premier producteur qui a reçu votre
cassette au départ il a cru que c'était
une diva noir en écoutant votre voix il
pouvait pas imaginer une seconde que
c'était un jeune anglais c'est une voie
que vous avez hérité de votre mère à ian
williams sonoma
oui absolument c'est une bonne série
tekken mais en fait j'ai fait une
interview à la radio à londres et le
type m'a dit c'est qui cette femme noire
qu'on entend la reine les jib annoncé
voilà
et là c'est le succès un succès
considérable et rapide vous donnez une
star mondiale vous donnez milliardaire
et vous devenez aussi cocaïnomane une
vingtaine d'années il ne faut pas croire
que l'on grandit à l'époque c'était les
années rock'n'roll mais les filles une
cagnotte de la vodka tard oued ont créé
par ça
il ya eu des petits débordements donc je
pense que l'idée c'était pas trop
d'aller plus loin c'est à cette époque
pour arriver à monter sur scène c'était
simplement l'espère de la scène et on
atterrit c'est parce qu'une fois que
vous avez joué votre spectacle il
fallait atterrir et l'atterrissage
parfois été un peu difficile de nous
ferons tomber là-dedans facilement
ferment c'est fini maintenant sur tout
j'ai été je suis prof depuis ce 5 e
moins 5 oui c'est terminé s'est terminée
aujourd'hui grâce à un ami à vous qui
s'appelle olic est un ami de longue date
et un jour vous rencontrez soli vous dit
qu'il a des problèmes d'argent
vous lui dites que vous avez des
problèmes de drogue et vous le dites je
vais de payer pour tu me surveille et
effectivement depuis le 1er janvier 2004
vous n'avez pas pris de drogue vous avez
l'air très bien là il ya quelqu'un qui a
été nommé vendredi lui dit non
d'ailleurs admis ce jeudi à holly à
l'époque sénateur sur place et je
l'avais beaucoup aidé il a beaucoup
voyagé pendant sa ville à dire pendant
les tours en amérique en amérique du sud
un peu partout et donc il était dans le
creux de la vague et donc je dis j'ai
dit elle je l'aider à redevenir heureux
donc je dis allez on est potes
j'ai besoin que tu m'aides à ton tour et
donc combien tu gagnes aller jeu musclé
part de ton salaire tu vas bosser
pendant 24 heures sur 24 on va se lever
le matin pour aller courir on va faire
ceci au travers on va arracher toutes
les pages des endroits où on peut sortir
accédera dont et si j'avais pas arrêté
de faire ça je n'aurais pas pu faire
dynamique et voilà
c
la même
autre chose cet extrait du nouvel album
moi je
qu'ils s'appellent
alors d'y aller car depuis que vous avez
arrêté la cocaïne nous est beaucoup plus
agréable avec les journalistes
il faut bien voir avec les paparazzi
anglais notamment c'est qu'ils sont
vraiment hyper fort et c'est vraiment
une musique endiablée veulent me voir
sortir des clubs un peu connaît l'état
qui veulent voir site la photo qui
veulent prendre et donc de temps en
temps alors fou et qui peindra tranché
tout le monde est content
alors qu'eric et vous
devenu un good guys un bon garçon et on
va faire une interview good guys
[Musique]
est ce que est ce que vous buvez encore
un peu quand même
oui combien problème ouais votre canne
tonique paulin est ce que vous fumez des
pétards de temps en temps pas autant
qu'avant mais ça m'arrive
serait ce sont les banel récupérer j'en
ai besoin après cette émission est ce
que vous êtes passés devant un juge
depuis moins d'un an
oui j'ai passé devant un juge
j'ai perdu mon permis de conduire dont
je les récupère entre temps mais enfin
j'ai permis aux curieux permis permis
conduire parce que je les ai trop vite
bien et beaucoup trop vite vous mettez
des pots catalytiques avons fait rare et
en fait toutes les ferrari sont équipées
de pots catalytiques
absolument et si vous partiez des
chapeaux il serait en fourrure
synthétique
alors oui complètement non en fourrure
naturelle jamais jamais est ce que
maintenant vous êtes un goût de gaye est
ce que vous pensez que rien n'est plus
beau que le sourire d'un enfant jay
raconte quelque chose si beaucoup de
calme il faut pas exagérer non
alors c'est clair entre nous j'ai
toujours bien les minettes qui pour des
mini jupes et des bottes ajustements ben
justement est ce que vous demandez
toujours la carte d'identité d'une fan
avant de coucher avec elle pour être sûr
qu'elle n'est pas mineure mon dieu non
non non est ce que maintenant vous êtes
un good guys vous rêvez d'un duo avec
mariah carey non la dernière fois que je
les ai vus d'ailleurs elle s'est pointée
comme ça yo avec les gens qui
l'entourent il était là dans le couloir
et les venues aller passer un comme ça
que je te tue des espions français que
l'amour pourrait sauver le monde
si vous débarrasser de georges bush dick
cheney et donald rumsfeld eh bien
peut-être que l'on pourrait sauver le
monde
m
le sol
joie gagne 1.31
le var
heureusement le 22 juillet
je
[Musique]
merci je vends commune thank you
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bagot régional ses méthodes
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]